[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut les terriens
bienvenue dans votre retour du samedi
soir bonsoir 4 terrière de choix avec
nous ce soir daphné burki
bürki bonsoir vous êtes ici ce soir pour
nous parler de le tube l'émission
consacrée aux médias que vous animerez
sur canal+ à partir du 14 septembre
prochain pour prendre rendez vous
avantage quand on présente une émission
sur l'actualité de la télé c'est qu'on
sait quand on va être viré
voilà patrick balkany
bonsoir vous êtes ici ce soir pour
assurer tout aux fans qui voyait plus
depuis quelques mois non vous n'êtes pas
mort non traité en prison
jamais d'ailleurs on serait tenté de
bien comment ça se fait
gilles lellouche
[Musique]
les tissus ce soit pour un livre
intitulé non je ne suis pas le fils de
claude lelouch s'était arrêté de me
faire chier avec un ami les fans c'est
bouleversant la balle à nicolas bedos
vous êtes ici ce soir pour répondre à la
question que la france entière se pose
le tai chi en ce moment
avec toi vous nous parler du magazine
elle vous écrivez désormais on n'est pas
couché où vous prenez crée parfois et
deux amours et turbulences qui sort en
dvd et de votre prochain livre la tête
ailleurs bref
[Musique]
c'est froid après le japon les gaspards
tous nous acquérons neutralité du samedi
20 heures ce soir malika ben ammar dont
le fils est mort d'une dizaine de coups
de couteau et une brise l'omerta des
cités de marseillaise nous sommes
ensemble jusqu'à 21 25 avec et les
gréement de fortune
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elvire bonsoir oui bonsoir alors je
voudrais d'abord préciser que votre vrai
nom et daphné burqa n'est qu'en ce
moment sa passion
les sexes alors des moments vous
commenciez le grand journal avec michel
denisot vous déclariez au magazine les
inrockuptibles je ne me sens pas du tout
potiche non le jour où ça arrivera je me
casserais très vite ce que j'aime à la
télé c'est que si tu ne fais pas la
faire les téléspectateurs n'ont plus
envie de te voir autour des gares
jacques te voilà que j'aime bien le net
et ce métier et quelques mois plus tard
ces images qui ont ému le haut
[Applaudissements]
de l'année l'ensemble
abu dhabi hors éléments et les circuits
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo aussi à la la mais c'est
complètement débile
mais moi aussi je vous remercie beaucoup
[Musique]
à
j'avais quitté le journal avant la fin
de la saison bayern en effet que
j'accouche quoi voilà mais alors la
question écologique est-ce que vous avez
pas fait un enfant pour quitter le grand
journal parce que vous en aviez marre de
mise au
pas du tout bon ah non c'est mon bébé
entend des seuils vous en voudrez
je regrette tellement souffert au grand
journal que vous avez préféré accoucher
sans péridurale parce que ça c'est
vraiment non j'ai eu ma drogue ça s'est
très très bien passé c'est vraiment un
très beau moment et je suis parti un peu
plus tôt que prévu c'est pour ça qu'on a
pleuré on s'y attendait foot vous devez
avoir un tas de questions en stock que
vous n'avez pas pu poser l'année
dernière
c'est possible j'en ai quelques hippies
et je tombe bien vous inviter dans mon
émission très bon
alors tu comme ça
une force de cas le grand journal que
vous avez développé une manière de
communiquer sans parler on va voir où
vous en êtes on va faire une interview
sans la bouche alors vous pouvez
répondre juste avec les mains ou le
visage
alors d'appeler comment allez vous
depuis que vous avez quitté le grand
journal
comment étaient vos relations avec
michel de liaison aux fins de saison
oui
il vous a fait un cadeau pour la
naissance de votre fille il vous a
offert quoi
une poupée
une télé
un godemiché n'ont
aucun rapport avec la forme en plus
allègrement pour dire godemichet gloire
se concentrer et des mois qu'avez vous
appris aux côtés de michel denisot dans
le grand journal
ah ouais
d'accord
gérer la pression est-ce que vous avez
songé à quitter canal après votre départ
du grand journal
comment trouvez-vous la formule du grand
journal avec antoine de caunes
de mieux en mieux
avec qui aimeriez vous travailler un
jour
je vous mettrais là
donc c'est pas son bureau
ça vaut le goût de parler
alors là je vais rassurer tous nos amis
téléspectateurs daphné est toujours sur
canal + vous la retrouverez tous les
samedis à 12h45 pour le tube l'émission
qui parle de l'actualité des médias
alors j'imagine que dans cette émission
vous allez répondre à toutes les
questions que les gens se posent sur les
médias et ceux qui les animent je veux
dire combien gagnent
s'ils ont envie d'en parler oui oui je
vais révéler où est passée ariane
massenet
je sais où elle va et où sur d8 assure
2010 18h01
excuses avait balancé sur qui couche
avec la miss météo de canal non
lâcherait rien là dessus alors
officiellement vous dites avoir quitté
le grand journal pour faire un enfant il
existe vraiment cet enfant
j'ai des photos plein mon portable et
oui alors comme j'ai demandé un jour
amanda lear fille ou garçon
c'est une fille et j'en suis sûr elle
s'appelle comment suzanne
la mauvaise foi bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
alors vos chroniques ont fait la joie
des téléspectateurs de franz-olivier
giesbert puis des lecteurs de marianne
elles sont désormais publiés dans le
journal
vous avez réalisé que les lectrices de
marianne était moche c'est ça
votre première chronique publiée le 30
août vous expliquer sur votre prétendue
misogynie oui c'était la moindre des
choses ouais quand tu rentres dans un
dans un dîner qui a des préjugés d'abord
tu commence par te justifier la presse
et youtube la bouteille et tu t'amuses
bien sûr moi je vous connais bien chez
vous n'êtes pas du tout misogyne au
contraire mais je j'ai été construits
élevé déterminé par les femmes par une
mère par trois soeurs à l'école seules
les filles s'intéresser à moi les gars
sont des énervés ils avaient des raisons
pour la plupart et après comme les fils
intéressés à moi je prenais la grosse
tête et gervais encore plus les garçons
et du coup au final voilà j'ai fini par
partager mes lectures mes goûts
cinématographiques
tout avec des filles avant même de faire
l'amour avec ce qui n'est pas
désagréable non plus nicolas c'est
marrant parce que depuis quelques temps
on a l'impression que vous avez des
trucs à nous dire jean je suis pas suite
vous croyez je suis un mec bien je suis
pas un drogué qui baise tout court
il a dit ça quand même si ça qu'on aime
chez mme en même temps toi voilà les
gens sont extrêmement déçus ils ont été
pas drogué quoi
alors en plus du lait faisait faire des
chroniques dans l'émission de laurent
ruquier le samedi soir sur france 2 me
en un an je vais m'amuser un peu oui à
regoûter à cet exercice que j'adore
c'est à dire écrire des choses et parler
de tout de la religion de la gauche de
la droite je serai libre de parler de
cul de parler de tout ce qui de tout ce
qui me passe par la plume je vais faire
ça gratuitement parce que je veux être
libre tel effort de barmak non non non
là en l'occurrence était c'était
important pour moi oui je vais y aller
peut-être trois fois quatre fois je les
remercie d'ailleurs de me donner cette
espèce de kars exemple si on n'est pas
couché sur le papier
moi je vous offre le double donc fait
partie de la bande à ruquier maintenant
comme
avec tout le respect que votre fiancée
ça la met pas trop de sortir avec un
chroniqueur de chiriqui voila voila
voila tu as compris un tout petit peu ce
qu'ils sont pas venus de la com pouvais
me casser les couilles c'est un peu ça
l'idée j'aime la télévision et en même
temps il ya un billet il ya un aspect de
la télévision quand je vois sur les
sites les blogs les maj etc c'est le
nouveau chroniqueur de ruquier ouais
tout d'un coup j'ai tout le monde se
mobilise mots qui me remonte dans la
gorge et j'ai très envie de rappeler que
je fais un film en novembre que j'ai mon
livre qui est publié dans un mois j'irai
où nous le respect que j'ai pour la
télévision je ne deviens pas comme steve
hill les restes il dit
bien en dessous des questions des gens
respectables donc tout à fait j'adore ce
style in bon et vous revenez ici donc
dans un mois un peu plus d'un mois pour
votre nouveau livre s'appelle la tête
ailleurs chez robert laffont oui je
prends un petit peu plus de risques
c'est un livre c'est un récit très
personnel sait pas c'est pas une fuite
d'eau chronique si ça c'est pas un livre
qui fait la graffeuse cette fois non
vraiment ce que je travaillais comme
mais là c'est un cetain c'est un livre
de totalement inédit gilles comment tu
les as à trouver alors pendant cette
première partie de l'émission moi je
trouve mon rémy nico brillant de toute
façon et ce qu'il dit sur la télé que ce
soit chez ruquier chez n'importe qui je
suis sûr qu'il sera brillant parce
qu'elle a des choses à dire finalement
aujourd'hui la télé elle est quand même
félicité par des gens qui n'ont rien à
dire donc quel que soit le média
durement qu'il a qui bossent s'exprimer
c'est une bonne chose
voilà c'était
discuter tous ensemble à l'actualité
[Musique]
bonsoir les terriers vraiment soin et
terrestres nous sommes sur la terre est
toujours en compagnie de neuf burki
balkany de gilles lellouche
et de nicolas bedos
alors patrick balkany re bonsoir donc je
vous rappelle que vous êtes député maire
de levallois perret ça va vous êtes
toujours à l'aise devant les caméras au
bois depuis le temps c'est l'habitude de
la vidéosurveillance à levallois ça ça
j'ai été le premier à mettre les caméras
maintenant tout le monde dormait oui il
ya comme une caméra levallois perret en
a pas tant que ça finalement on va en
rajouter
et on a passé tout le monde en réclame
c'est la ville où il ya intéressante
irna qui est défini des zones et c'est
vrai qu'on voit bien avec don caméra
même la nuit un oui et on arrive à lire
une plaque minéralogique à 200 m oh là
là à la faux pas brûler les feux rouges
quelle horreur c'est vraiment génial
nouvelle mais ça évite les accidents
voilà quel est l'endroit le plus étrange
il ya les caméras de surveillance dans
votre ville y en a partout mais si on
baisse vont embarquer bon il vaut mieux
aller à l'auteur il n'y en a pas les
moyens d'aller à l'hôtel mais je sors
n'habitent pas de valloire chose
savaient pas de vous aviez encore cette
déviance
s'est fiancé moi je suis fiancée aux
invités ce soir parce que dans ces
tentes dans tous besoin de retrouver
confiance dans la politique je tenais à
avoir à mes côtés celui qui se définit
lui même comme l'homme le plus honnête
du monde
dans cette émission vous savez
il vaut mieux à quand on fait de la
politique oui parce qu'on est vous avez
remarqué extrêmement
surveillé oui par les médias par les
procureurs parlent et l'élu il est tout
le monde essaye toujours de vous trouver
des noirs et donc il vaut mieux être
clim
vous n'êtes pas par exemple l'homme
politique le plus honnête du monde par
rapport à pasqua non
pasqua moi j'ai beaucoup d'admiration
pour pour pasqua qui était un grand
ministre un grand ministre de
l'intérieur qui a été un grands patrons
v des hauts-de-seine grand président du
conseil général je vais vous dire si
vous voulez pas être honnête faut faire
autre chose que de la tête et personne
n'a jamais fait de politique vous êtes
quand même gonflé le faire gorrite et de
l'argent où et quand même utiliser la
conjugaison pour dire je suis devenu
récemment honnête mais mais mais le
présent est un peu affirmée est un peu
et humble gonflé je ne vois vraiment pas
qu'est ce qui vous autorise parce que
qu'est ce qui vous autorise à dire des
choses pareilles je vous rappel des
faits qu'elle trouve que vous parlez de
la de la confiance que les français
doivent retrouver à la politique vous
voyez un homme qui comme vous a eu des
démêlés avec la justice oui on m'a
reproché il ya 20 ans d'avoir
employés canadiens qui recevait les
chefs d'entreprise qui servait comme le
font tous les ministres
c'est derrière moi vous avez raison vous
avez raison mais c'est normal à un
moment donné il y avait les gens ont de
la mémoire c'est normal que que ça
puisse paraître une descente donc va le
gagner ce gars est la caméra et dit je
sens religieux l'homme le plus honnête
il soit dans cet agaçant mais où j'ai eu
beau dos ça fait trente ans que je suis
maire vous savez réélu par une
population qui voit ce que je fais dans
ma ville et si je suis député depuis 88
c'est pas par hasard c'est parce que je
suis élu au suffrage d'univers ce
message de romanée vous y frotter un
jour et j'ai pas que ça vous verrez que
ce n'est pas si facile et quand on veut
donner des leçons jda n'a pas de sens
quand on veut donner des leçons aux
politiques allez vous faire élire et
nouveau site idée quand même qu'on
puisse plus critique est un homme
politique sans être passés soit même pas
le suffrage universel on ça va être de
plus en plus compliqué de commenter la
politique s'il faut soi-même est très lu
jill t'es pas obligé de faire la gueule
que tu fais dans ton film
et
bon
rien cette mise au point est en fait
toute façon vous n'êtes pas impliqué
patrick dans les affaires qui
empoisonnent la vie de votre grand ami
sarkozy karachi kadhafi bettencourt
arbitrage tapis voilà maintenant et
pourtant vous n'êtes pas tu as vécu je
suis très ami avec nicolas sarkozy que
vous êtes ami avec une absolument c'est
l'époque où son père était aux usa et
lui sarko il avait pas de blé il était
tout seul et vous voulez dire oui c'est
vrai oui moi j'étais déjà mariés ils
venaient manger à la maison
j'avais une affaire de prêt-à-porter ils
veulent s habiller bon très bien voilà
c'était mon l'avait aidé et je les ai
d'eads était jeune il a six ans de moins
que moi il était et c'est son droit il
n'avait pas de soul le samedi et le
dimanche s'il allait bosser il allait
vente des glaces le samedi vente des
fleurs le dimanche se trimballer les
gros pots etc et puis après il est
devenu maire de neuilly très bien voilà
lorsque vous avez raccroché en fait
c'est que vous êtes d'origine hongroise
tous les deux à l'est et en revanche lui
son père assumer pas très bien son rôle
de père de famille alors que vous il
était divorcé voilà voilà alors que vous
allez y avait de l'argent votre père il
allait et conduite exemplaire pendant la
résistance déporté à auschwitz et à des
résistants officier de la légion
d'honneur médaille militaire
c'est à dire avant d'avoir été
naturalisée française en 49 voilà et
ensuite votre père a monté une
entreprise de prêt-à-porter tout à qui
s'appelait réty tu te souviens pas il
faisait des bikinis avait des voitures
red sea qui circulait dans paris il en
est c'est vrai
ça marche a dit avec du pognon comme un
regret il y avait de quoi s'occuper de
ce pauvre nicolas sarkozy
alors j'ai toujours défendu nicolas
sarkozy bec et ongles et quand jean
françois copé veut faire un bilan du
quinquennat vous dit jean françois copé
ferait mieux de faire l'inventaire des
conneries de la gauche depuis un an ce
qu'il ne fait d'ailleurs pas beaucoup en
ce moment alors c'est celle pendant
l'été copé quand c'était pour la
présidence de l'ump ou le soutenir je me
suis élancé pour les visées vous le
soutenez pas du tout écoutez je pense
très sincèrement que cette bataille pour
l'elysée est tout à fait prématuré c'est
dans quatre ans donc je suis contre ces
écuries présidentielles
je pense que on en a le temps d'en
parler moi je souhaite que nicolas
sarkozy revienne le moment venu c'est
lui qui décidera s'il revient s'il
revient pas et puis ça sera le moment de
parler des présidentielles pas
aujourd'hui alors vu que vous êtes là on
va en profiter sur la syrie quelle est
votre position est la position de
sarkozy est ce que comme en libye vous
voulez remplacer un dictateur laïque par
une dictature islamique et est
déstabilisé toute une région je pense
que vraiment on ne peut pas intervenir
la base sans qu'il y ait vraiment une
coalition et sous couvert de l'onu on ne
peut pas aujourd'hui nous les français
parce que le président de la république
a décidé de d'être le général
va-t-en-guerre de partir régler tous les
problèmes qui se posent partout cela dit
ce qui a été fait est parfaitement
horrible même dégueulasse d'avoir envoyé
un des gages sur les gens sayah ya aucun
problème mais ce qui est curieux c'est
que tant qu'on l'ait tué à coups de
fusil ou coup de canon tout le monde
trouvait ça normal et quand ils sont
morts avec le gaz sarin alors l'un c'est
horrible cela dit les français pensent
et à juste titre que ce n'est pas leur
guerre mais que ce n'est pas à la france
n'était pas la chaussure leur avait
demandé j'étais pas non plus trop quand
on aime
oui nous n'avons pas d'intérêt
particulier
en syrie nous n'avons pas d'intérêt
français particulier à protéger là bas
me suis dit est-ce qu'on est obligé
d'intervenir simplement ou à cause des
intérêts particuliers qu'on avait ce
qu'on pourrait pas juste intervenir par
par altruisme simplement pour sauver des
gens qui se font massacrer oui avec un
peu de noblesse sont serrés aucun je ne
sais pas je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec vous et c'est le rôle de l'onu et
l'ue était normal même si le conseil de
sécurité s'y opposait parce que les
russes et les chinois s'y opposaient ce
qui aurait été normal c'est que ban ki
moon le secrétaire général convoque
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
et fassent voter à la majorité simple
l'intervention par l'onu qui à ce moment
là aurait pu récupérer des soldats des
avions etc dans toutes les les grandes
puissances et intervenir au nom de l'onu
mais la france n'est pas gendarme du
monde mais l'opinion voit bien à son
incapacité à gérer cette situation mais
je sais très bien donc clairement donné
il va falloir faire à être actif on pas
regarder ce massacre éternellement je
veux dire on est d'accord mais on ne
peut pas aller nous tout seuls s'il n'y
a pas des pas question d'y aller tout se
passe il ya en face à la coalition des
grandes puissances militaires s il est
impossible d'y aller seul si colas
danger est ce que tu penses que l'armée
française doit rétablir leur vin
marseille ou en syrie
où là je suis bien trop lâches pour
répondre à cette question on va parler
de la syrie ça ferait pas de mal pour
mettre un peu de militaires dans
certaines banlieues
droite
samia ghali qui socialistes qui
réclament sa
si monsieur
valls n'est pas capable de régler le
problème il faut qu'ils s'adressent le
payant 115,56 partie écrire non elle en
fait oui j'ai faim j'ai fait un rêve au
mois de juillet pardon c'est pas contre
vous personnellement que
dans le mot rêve je me balade j'étais
ils étaient tous sur une plage j'avais
fab us valse balkanique copé il était en
bermuda comme ça ils étaient en train
déjà de préparer leur petit tacle leur
petit clash leur petit buzz de l'année
qui s'annonce avec les mêmes des
journalistes et a pâti toute la clique
il était là sur la plage il y avait un
immense tsunami
qui arrivait comme ça au loin et tout le
monde
mais au moins on mettait des nouvelles
tronche dans la sauce de la société
civile il restait plus personne à bouaye
et nicolas c'est pourquoi je vais pas à
la plage
s'est mieux passé de 20 ans sur les
hauteurs
alors gilles lellouche pour le soir
vous savez
du geiq la seule star à s'appeler gila
mais je sais je sais gilles moreton mais
j'en veux tellement mes parents de
m'avoir apg ouais c'est quoi ce qui
n'est pas gilles c'est un prénom de
berger mais c'est pas un peu nom
d'acteur je suis le frère de philippe
lellouche qui lui même est le mari de
vanessa demouy ouais vous êtes également
l'ami de jean dujardin ouais tout comme
nicolas bedos avoir une liste d'attentes
incroyable pour devenir ami de jean
dujardin via des bus alors allez-vous
dans les années 60 il y avait ce qu'on
appelait leurs attaques alors c'était
frank sinatra dean martin sammy davis
junior peter lawford et en france ont à
leur attaque maintenant notre rate pas
qu'à nous c'est jean dujardin gilles
lellouche et nicolas bedos alors pour
entrer dans la bande c'est c'est
compliqué il faut boire trois vodkas
tonique par le
raconter des blagues de cul et shopping
9 en moins de dix minutes d'une
avoir lu un livre avoir lu un livre j'ai
oublié donc ne pas être alessandra
sublet
bon alors vous êtes très copains on est
très copain denis même oui mais ça fait
long ça fait très longtemps qu'on se
connaît tous et donc c'est pas du tout
une amitié opportuniste ou ou
professionnels ce qu'on est on est potes
vraiment et vous êtes très proche de
jean donc vous d'ailleurs dans la scène
de sodomie des infidèles oui c'est un
fait que la cascade tout faire en vrai
vous savez que ça on l'a tiré au sort
quand même ouais on l'a fait à pile ou
face et j'ai gagné en faveur des
meilleurs jarrier du de bordeaux
que j'avais la meilleure position
c'est toi qui a eu cette idée en plus
non mais moi je trouve que tu as perdu
j'ai parlé de la possibilité qu'à la fin
du film il ya cette conclusion se disent
vraiment il était très très drôle
dialogue puisque ce qu'une connerie
c'est que ces conneries vous arrêtez de
délirer les voilà donc j'y vais pas
c'est comme ça que tu es vite donc je
bien d'habitude qui te pètes victoire
mais voilà
alors jls est ici ce soit pour un film
sans jean dujardin ça m'arrive de temps
en temps 5 robert ouimet lorsqu'isabelle
gibraltar c'est bon c'est un film de
julien leclercq qui avait réalisé
l'assaut avec tahar rahim riccardo
scamarcio
celui de romanzo criminale de l'énorme
dossier bien entendu alors c'est
l'histoire de marc duval donc un
français expatrié à gibraltar qui pour
mettre sa famille à l'abri du besoin
devient aviseur des douanes françaises
et se retrouve embarqué dans l'univers
des narcotrafiquants c'est l'histoire
d'un film assez sombre assez c'est dur
c'est non seulement dur mais c'est
surtout une histoire vraie ouais
histoire de marie fievet marc fiévet qui
s'est vraiment arriver et qui a dédié
six ans et demi de sa vie à cette
entourloupe l'arrêt et dix ans de prison
surtout il avait un espèce de bar
restaurant dans lequel tous les
narcotrafiquants se retrouver pour jouer
au billard et il discutait de leur
trafic et donc on l'aurait on lui a
demandé de venir indique d'un 10 qu'il
est devenu convoyeur de convoyeurs il
est devenu lui-même dealer enfin il se
trouvait dans une position inouïe way en
étant censés être protégés par l'état ce
qu'il était dans environ 20 vraiment
protégé il était trahi qui avaient leur
était très sale indique légal qui a été
trahi par les temps exactement ces
tragiques comme histoire on regarde à
quoi ça ressemble je dois dépôt de bilan
la suisse et des banques je comprends
pourquoi vous êtes venu à gibraltar et
peut-être trouvé une solution pour nous
donner un peu d'air
j'ai rencontré un douanier qui me fait
une proposition tu comptes balançait
tout les mecs qui passent par ici le
trafiquant sts
moi je vois ça qu'est ce que j'ai gagné
10% mais tout ce qu'on récupère va où là
n'est pas assez bien notre vie c'est pas
notre part mais c'est pas tous et des
crédits qui s'accumulent combat je pas
remboursé c'est sa neutralité c'est ça
nous dit
[Musique]
désormais tulmont fait dans la drogue
c'est du vol on peut convertir leurs
gros billets aux normes de guerre
j'étais proposé pour une opération de
convoyage les gars vous faites pour la
publicité monsieur duval grosse saisie
de drogue et ça montre aux gens que les
douaniers seront moins aussi important
que les pompiers
écoute moi à ta famille au cepsum en
protection de la bonne foi
[Musique]
duchaussoy tiers
du podium
j'ai besoin de cet argent
monsieur de balle vous êtes un menteur
et vous avez peur j'ai peur je suis
maman je suis pas un menteur
tu crois quoi tu feras pas au grand
frère c'est ça il ya peu par agen
j'étais là au moment où j'en avais
besoin jetez jamais vu
c'est l'un des plus gros
narcotrafiquants il est dangereux mais
je comprends
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai plus confiance en toi mais il m'a
dit plus confiance en personne
lascaux trafiquants pour eux je
travaille pour l'état je travaille pour
les banques françaises je trouve pour
toi
[Musique]
tu fais pas tu ne perds pas confiance
d'accord je vais faire une seule c'est
fini
voilà six mois le cardinal coeur ça sort
mercredi
même sans du jardin c'est bien
d'ailleurs en sortir même si on lui en
ce moment vous tourner avec lui je vais
par la semaine prochaine relance la
french et c'est l'histoire du juge
michel exécuté de deux balles dans la
tête et une dans le thorax par le milieu
marseillais alors à l'époque ça avait
beaucoup choqué maintenant à marseille
c'est une mort naturelle
quasi alors on passe maintenant à
l'actualité de la terre avec l'édito de
blacko et c'est françois corbère anciens
détenus devenue juriste que nous
retrouverons sur ce plateau après le
magnéto ce soir nous parlerons de la
réforme taubira faut-il libérer les
délinquants patrick je vous jure on n'a
pas fait parce que vous êtes là
faut-il libérer tous les délinquants qui
sont en prison au départ c'est ce que ce
soit et christiane taubira que tous les
détenus condamnés à moins de 5 ans de
prison soit libéré après avoir purgé les
deux tiers de leur peine selon la
ministre de la justice enfermer les gens
mais jamais la bonne solution nous
allons détruire
pulvérisé la méthode qui consiste à
prétendre que le bon sens veut qu'il
faut enfermer et enfermé et enfermé sans
cesse sacré christiane quand il s'agit
de faire grimper la droite aux rideaux
on peut toujours compter sur elle pour
elle nous dit elle la prison créée de la
délinquance pourtant la vérité c'est que
c'est l'impunité qui crée la délinquance
à l'ump on rêve d'en fermer tous les
délinquants en prison
comme ça les honnêtes gens pourraient
vivre tranquillement sans avoir rien à
craindre
mais pour que cette méthode soit
vraiment efficace il faudrait que les
délinquants qu'on met en prison en
sortent jamais or ce n'est pas le cas il
est donc important de préparer la
réinsertion des détenus dans la société
toutes les études menées sur le sujet
prouve que la prison favorise la
récidive quand un jeune délinquant passe
plusieurs mois enfermé avec roccat
revoyons endurcis c'est un peu comme
s'il suivait des cours à l'école du
crime la preuve tous sarkozy on n'en
voyait de plus en plus de gens en prison
pour des peines plus en plus longues
résultat le taux de récidive n'a cessé
d'augmenter c'est pour ça qu'au lieu de
laisser croupir les délinquants en
prison taubira voudrait instaurer une
période de probation les récidivistes
doille sortir progressivement
avec
un contrôle et des contraintes on libère
le détenu au deux tiers de sa peine mais
attention on continue à le surveiller à
l'encadrer bientôt grâce à te dire à
quand un vilain garnement a racheté le
sac à main d'une mamie au lieu de
l'envoyer en prison on le condamnera à
porter les sacs de la vie dame
lorsqu'elle ira faire ses courses et
comme ça tous les honnêtes gens pourront
enfin vivre en paix
voilà c'était les vitres de draco mise
en image de julien gras soit quand mr
bonsoir vous êtes ancien détenu vous
avez une juriste autodidacte vous êtes
surnommé robin des lois derrière ce nom
de votre association
bienvenue parmi nous merci alors après
le mariage pour tous les socialistes
tous deux vont ils inventer la prison
pour personne on va en parler
christiane taubira veut que les
condamnés à moins de 5 ans de prison
soit libérée aux deux tiers de leur
peine pour une période de probation pour
la gauche la prison créée la récidive
pour la droite c'est l'impunité qui crée
la récidive alors patrick balkany oui
c'est un très mauvais signe que madame
taubira
donne au monde délinquants comment
voulez-vous que travaillent les
policiers si une fois arrêté on leur dit
non non les petits pas en prison soyez
sages retournez chez vous à l'édile est
allé voler les voitures c'est de la
petite délinquance en plus c'est vrai
mais je pense que la prison ne fait
plaisir à personne et que celui qui fait
sa peine en prison peut-être a pas
forcément envie de récidiver
celui à qui on dit tu es condamné mais
tu fais pas de de tôle bon alors si je
fais pas de tôle quand je suis condamné
autant que je recommence à à voler a
dealé et cetera bon je suis pas sûr que
ce soit la position n est pas due aussi
aux prisons un peu foireuse quand même
non je crois qu'il ya introduit enfin
tout même la droite le sait ce n'est pas
une question droite gauche parce que là
vous mélangez absolument tout et des
petits délinquants et puis les faits
divers horrible pourvoi au 20h place
dans votre bonne ville de levallois wire
il ya effectivement cette petite
délinquance est un poison de la vie des
gens j'assure simplement il faut savoir
que 80 % des gens qui sont dans nos
prisons il nous prison parce que c'est
les vôtres les miennes financée par les
impôts de tous bien sûr et ça fonctionne
pas vous savez très bien puisque la loi
pénitentiaire qui a été porté par
rachida dati était déjà si on prend les
paramètres aujourd'hui laxiste qu'avait
fait rachida dati parce que remplir les
prisons ça sert à rien on y met
aujourd'hui des gens on voyait pas il ya
20 ans prison on y voyait que des voyous
ce qui est pas péjoratif dans la bouche
aujourd'hui du fait d'une pénalisation
de la société qui a cru vous savez très
bien depuis dix ans un fait divers une
loi un fait divers une loi on sait l'un
plus d'ailleurs quelles sont les lois
patrick effectivement c'est le mélange
est ce que on a on n'a évidemment pas
intérêt à mettre des primo-délinquants
avec des oui parce que l'afrique vient
également parce que ça met with jools et
là d'où il faut se tenir à c'est pas du
tout ne pas enfermer les voyous les
méchants et durs ceux qui savent qu'ils
prennent des risques en allant braquer
d'ailleurs il accepte la règle du jeu
simplement c'est jazz attendez attendez
attendez moi il ya comme un truc c'est
que quand elle dit les gens qui sont
donnés à moins de 5 ans aux deux tiers
de leur peine ils sortent est ce que
vous savez ce que couvre cinq ans de
prison c'est quand même des gens c'est
des gens qui ont faim détention d'armes
passés d'une incitation à la pédo
pornographie
tentative d'agression sexuelle alors si
ces gens là ils sont libérés des trois
ans il voudrait que ça peut inquiéter
les citoyens vous êtes d'accord l'idée
de christiane taubira ces deux pour les
peines allant jusqu'à cinq ans mais
encore une fois il n'y avait pas les
magistrats auront leur liberté d'après
d'apprécier c'est de faire en sorte de
créer une panne de probation qui va
s'appeler contraintes pénale est une
autre palette à la disposition du juge
que juste quand il n'a pas le choix la
tentation c'est fort dangereux en prison
c'est facile en stock c'est comme ça que
la population carcérale explose
l'approbation ça existe déjà plus ou
moins de sursis avec mise à l'épreuve
bon ça serait un peu la même chose mais
plus renforcé plus individualisé bon
deuxième dans la conditionnelle ou on
vous pousse à avoir à faire de démarche
pas en vous mais comme ça dort c'est
bien aussi parce qu'il ya des gens au
bout de 5 ans 10 ans ils n'ont plus
l'énergie et ils attendent la sortie de
leur peine à phan thanh soit pas les
sorties sèches ce soit les petits
délinquants ou des moyens ou des grands
qui sont à la rue souvent ils n'ont pas
de travail et c'est là une façon de
récidiver parce que vous êtes à la rue
oui bien sûr moi je suis sûr ça pourrait
paraître un peu loin des réalités moi
j'ai été très très intéressé dans la
petite éducation philosophique par les
écrits de foucault dans certaines texte
de cabu et c'est pour qui la prison
philosophiquement c'est un échec c'est à
dire pour qui la prison telle qu'elle
est en tout cas la surenchère et précis
la répression à tout bout de champ fâche
le coupable avec la société et par
excellence ça crée une sorte de
contradiction avec le fait de lui dire
cette société elle va te t'accueillir
elle va te réaccueillir elle va te
reprendre en son sein la prison c'est
une claque et qui me donne une claque
moi je n'ai pas forcément envie de jouer
son jeu par la suite patrick à mon sens
le vrai problème des prisonniers
aujourd'hui c'est que vous avez ceux qui
sont dangereux pour la société et qu'il
faut garder derrière les barreaux et
ceux qui ne présentent pas de danger
pour la société et qu'on doit
et dont on doit s'occuper du suivi et de
la réinsertion justement à l'enfant soit
170 mille détenus combien on peut en
libère pour lâcher 10000 15000 ouais
enfin il faut pas les lâcher il faut les
sanctionner ceux qui sont capables de
rentrer avec des peines différentes y a
pas que la prison chez nous en france
depuis 200 ans on vit avec il a fait une
connerie on l'envoie en prison vous
n'êtes pas dans d'autres pays c'est pas
du tout ça et ça marche très bien aux
pays bas on parle pas de surpopulation
carcérale c'est pas à new york c'est
tout près il faut aller voir
ils louent même fait une anecdote mais
ils louent des places aux belges la
place en prison pays bas 9 à castres ce
qu'ils ont développé des procédures de
swan dont nous manquons on manque de
psychiatres donc on n'en marquait déjà
une aile pas en prison les dealers de
shit ce qui est déjà pas mal un point de
vue mais bon chacun
ça dépend il ya dix leur est d'ailleurs
celui qui ramène 500 kg et ceux qui qui
fournit la soirée fait ça pour fournir
la soirée il faut créer un carnet s'agit
d'un créneau françoise séris à fait à
notre égard c'est la dépénalisation
pas débat ça pas à l'ordre du jour donc
vite et de taubira c'est de sanctionner
autrement disons cinq mille personnes ça
viderait déjà un peu pas vider toutes
les prisons elle a jamais dit ça alors
justement nous avons en france un maton
pour trois détenus et un conseiller
pénitentiaire pour 57 personnes donc
voilà où est le problème c'est à dire
qu'en france il ya beaucoup plus de gens
pour surveiller les prisonniers que pour
appliquer des pelles de réagir sauter
sur la belle une question d'argent on
est abruti d'impôts on va pas en plus
d'avoir un impôt supplémentaire pour
aider les détenus fossé semblerait c'est
à voter les faits regarde ma bulle et il
semblerait qu'ils aient 300 postes
beaucoup c'est une si c'est voter pour
2014 de recrutement de conseillers
d'insertion et devant la nation eux le
demande depuis des années c'est évident
que suivi laisse à désirer quand on
libère quelqu'un le bracelet c'est pas
magique ça marche mais s'il n'y a pas
une aide c'est pas seulement la
surveillance c'est aider quelqu'un à
faire des démarches de brest
électronique oui moi j'aime pas
ça puisse à vous je suis imagine donc la
droite revient de pouvoir dans trois ans
peu importe moi je ne veux pas m'engager
sur ses ailes aurait exactement le même
problème aujourd'hui puisque on n'a
jamais eu autant de monde en prison ça
ne marche pas on n'a pas les moyens de
faire fonctionner nos prisons actuelles
donc l'autre version qui est on
construit 25000 places ce qui avait été
voté juste avant l'examen avec quoi
comment on fait personne ne pourrait
financer ça aujourd'hui bien en fait le
projet au moins le mérite qu'on
s'intéresse à mon président on s'y
intéresse de très bons avocats de madame
taubira c'est vrai je suis par jean et
c'est vrai c'est convaincant quand même
moi je trouve ça assez convaincant ouais
moi je dois encore vaincu mais je crois
que patrick balkany
même patrick balkany est convaincu donc
je suis pas convaincu par mam taubira
parce qu'elle fait exprès de faire de la
provoc oui
et y compris avec mon anus de la tune on
est d'accord kristjan telve aux 80 ans
j'en ai compris avec va merci françois
merci d'avoir été avec nous gilles merci
d'avoir été avec nous c'était la paix de
l'esprit on se retrouve après la pub
avec le cercle gaspard est notre invité
du 20 heures jean marie cavada marre
oui ces normes du j'aime le foot
m
baisieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en ramant son éternel roman soit le cas
nous sommes toujours en compagnie de
daphné burki
nicolas benausse
nous accueillons votre invité du samedi
20 heures ce soir malika ben ammar
bonsoir
alors malika il ya trois ans votre fils
était assassiné d'une dizaine de coups
de couteau en mars dernier c'est son
assassin qui était retrouvé mort au pied
d'un immeuble tout le monde savait pour
votre fils mais la police n'avait jamais
pu arrêter l'assassin faute de
témoignage la peur des représailles
aujourd'hui vous briser la loi du
silence vous nous raconter votre
histoire à 20 heures maintenant
j'accueille gaspard proust pour elle est
pas belle la vie
[Musique]
ça lui vient ce pas bonjour bonjour
c'est salut salut je suis vraiment très
content de reprendre ben voila je tenais
à le dire parce que ça se voie pas
toujours sur mon visage et c'est un vrai
bonheur de donner du plaisir aux gens
tout cas public vraiment merci du fond
du coeur pour volailles que vos tweets
et enfin tous vos pouces que vous mettez
sous la vidéo sur le site canal pour
dire que la vidéo est au-dess us et
c'est vraiment un geste pratique parce
que sinon on la trouverait pas et
alors moi c'était bon je suis assez
férus de culture je n'aime pas trop les
endroits chauds donc je suis allé à
dubaï
c'est beau c'est beau dubaï c'est c'est
comme la défense mais au milieu du sahel
quoi si tu détestes la nature c'est
vraiment un chouette endroit pour lâcher
prise
[Applaudissements]
alors bon
la main d'oeuvre au cc que des
pakistanais des indiens des sri lankais
ça fait ça fait bizarre au début c'est
parce que de visu physiquement on dirait
un peu des roms alors et mais en fait
ils te demandent juste alors est ce que
la viande est bien cuite encore un
mojito et on l'a retrouvé votre
portefeuille ça fait bizarre au début
et je te parle pas des femmes parce que
là bas les femmes
cccc d'une pudeur tout dans les yeux
c'est bon c'est normal tout le reste est
couvert quand je te dire que tu as
l'impression qu'elles passent leur temps
à chercher un bloc opératoire
alors bon au niveau culture je suis pas
rentré bredouille il fallait quand même
visiter un musée par là bas ils
appellent ça un centre commercial
j'ai déniché un très très chouette
bibelots que je voulais donc c'est c'est
un mug fao
osez le féminisme
d'ailleurs j'ai bu une vodka dedans je
me suis trouvé super subversif la
bombe enfin bref sinon qu'est ce qui
s'est passé récemment alors le devoir de
vacances des ministres a été de pondre
un rapport sur ce que sera la france en
2025 alors ils sont tous optimistes
c'est le rapport qui aurait pu s'appeler
ça ira mieux quand on sera plus là
c'est
ce genre c'est un truc après nous le
paradis quoi bon en gros en 2025 tout
sera réglé c'est quand même bizarre que
des gens de gauche qui sont convaincus
que tout sera génial quand le fn sera au
pouvoir
c'est ça se raconte à je veux dire fn en
2025 c'est philippe au ministre de la
justice serge ayoub ministre de la
culture facile
alors au pif à l'ordre dans les
prospectives ya montebourg qui prévoit
qu'en 2025 qui aura la france qui fera
partie du concert des grandes nations
industrielles il annonce qu on va
inventer un moyen de transport qui
consomme 2 litres aux cent
ça existe déjà ça s'appelle un cheval
[Musique]
ils sont tous en 2025 najat vallaud
belkacem sera majeur
un peu de patience pour les mecs
sinon quoi d'autre alors oui il ya un
mouvement alors j'ai cité osez le
féminisme ça à peu en vrac un qui milite
pour l'entrée des femmes au panthéon moi
je suis pour après la question pourquoi
seulement des femmes mortes
alors elles ont toutes en commun un truc
elles défendent la cause des femmes bon
si on fait entrer au panthéon des femmes
juste parce qu'elles défendent les
femmes alors de la même manière pour les
hommes pourra prévoir une place pour
bigard et dsk
[Applaudissements]
ac aurait l'été c'est aussi l'amour
c'est important quand la love story de
l'été valls taubira est une révélation
la prison créée des délinquants c'est
vrai en général les mecs qui arrivent en
prison c'est parce qu'ils ont été
acquittés
alors on veut réduire la peine de prison
m des peine probatoire on a raison à
l'horizon faute avouée faute à moitié
pardonnée faux faux des prisons plus
spacieuse et confortable
moi je vois depuis que le club med a
retapé ces villages j'ai plus de plaisir
à y aller
je sais pas
non faut sortir d'une certaine démagogie
si je peux me permettre
parce que si un mec est en prison c'est
que quelque part il ya une injustice moi
je connais des victimes
qu'est ce qu'une personne âgée fou avec
100 euros en liquide dans son sac à main
statistiquement 100 % des victimes ont
croisé un agresseur
dire la provoc un moment ça suffit quoi
et on l'oubli mais souvent le délinquant
est plus dans le besoin financier que la
victime
à part ça oui j'allais oublier un truc
super important la commémoration alors
il ya une semaine c'était le 50e
anniversaire du discours à and dreams
c'est quand même très émouvant
cet homme qui parce qu'il est noir est
obligé de raconter son rêve en dehors
d'un cabinet de psy car
la pauvreté ça pousse toujours à la
pudeur
la syrie aurait parié que ça bouge là
bas
c'est les attaques chimiques alors ils
ont envoyé des experts pour vérifier je
sais pas si christine boutin était dans
l'équipe parce qu'elle s'est fait gazer
bah ouais
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr
s était de gaz et par l'intervention
internationale
mais ça c'est notre rapport aux
personnes âgées quand on sera toujours
plus émues par un enfant musulman qui
suffoque une grand mère catholique qui
tousse
et le problème c'est le côté c'est le
mot chimiques c'est le côté gazage ça
rappelle les heures sombres quoi tu sais
les gens il suit supporte pas ça leur
rappelle trop quand il se trouve coincé
aux heures de pointe sur le périph dans
un tunnel bagnolet
en fait les armes chimiques c'est un peu
comme la fellation pas comme sucer n'est
pas trompé flinguer n'est pas exterminer
en tout cas la maréchal des logis-chef
la hollande il veut y aller
tu es à côté d'obama ce gendarme de
saint tropez qui se tirent la bourre
avec rambo quoi
[Applaudissements]
mais
ça
s'explique c'est l'effet mali quoi
depuis qu'il a cartonné là-bas choristes
et olemps que c'est un peu
l'enthousiaste du la fougue du mec qui
vient tout juste de perdre son pucelage
quoi c'est le type il vient de se taper
la fille facile du village et qui va
raconter à tous ses potes c'est le loup
blanc dans tous les bars à [__] de
saigon
pas le mali et la syrie doit il faut
expliquer un peu la syrie ces essais
c'est un pays c'est pas un paysage
et chef du village c'est pas un chaman
qui lit dans les entrailles de patates
douces
ce que bachar il a un certain classement
tu lui mets un haut de forme un
parapluie série glee show man à damas
après faut être juste il faut être juste
est ce que la france peut intervenir
tout seul oui
ben oui on envoyait une frégate de
zodiac face et on parle aussi de deux
ulm peut-être 3 6 1 arthus bertrand
répond oui
[Applaudissements]
va finir par une bonne nouvelle peut
être pas plomber sur la guerre
l'allocation adulte handicapé va aussi
augmenter de 1 75% cette année joli coup
de pouce au pouvoir d'achat des
fonctionnaires
alors pas belle la vie
d'ici là demain
sur canal+ les calais à 15 heures et le
sur sur canalplus.fr scheer terriens
vous pouvez suivre l'actu de la mission
à réagir sur twitter via le compte les
terriens et le hashtag est celle t on
passe maintenant à notre invité du
samedi 20 heures
[Musique]
malika ben ammar bonsoir vous êtes né le
16 avril 1965 à aïn el turck un petit
village au bord de la mer à 16
kilomètres d'oran en algérie père maçon
mère femme au foyer elle avait de quoi
s'occuper puisque vous étiez neuf
enfants vous avez deux ans quand votre
famille quitte l'algérie pour marseille
vous vous installez dans un grand
appartement cité coraux dans les
quartiers nord à l'époque c'était très
calme oui
effectivement vous dites on s'entraide
et on se mélange les cathos aller à
l'église les juifs à la synagogue les
musulmans à la mosquée et le malt 1 on
allait à l'école plus ensemble je n'ai
pas cassé heureuse finalement sur la
scène souvenirs négatifs quand vous êtes
un adolescente il ya aucun problème dans
le quartier il n'y a pas de trafic a pas
de règlement de compte à l'époque pas du
tout on fermait même pas les portes à
l'époque hein je veux dire un port
d'entrée ce terme est rarement alors
venus fêter vos 18 ans lorsque vous
perdez votre maman est là après quelques
mois d'errance sur la côte d'azur pour
noyer votre chagrin vous devenez femme
de chambre dans l'hôtellerie ensuite
vous êtes recruté par une ligne de
prêt-à-porter
et c'est là que vous rencontrez le père
de vos enfants exactement alors vous
avez deux enfants et roanne c'est ça et
cinq ans après une petite fille mais le
père de vos enfants
disparaît assez vite du paysage ils
étaient pas fait pour le rôle de père il
a assumé pas et apparemment vous lui en
voulez pas beaucoup mais moi je suis là
pour les aimer je suis là pour
pour as aimé dieu sait si vous avez aimé
après plus d'un an de rmi vous entrez
dans une entreprise de nettoyage vous
travaillez encore aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
toutes ces années après alors erwan
votre fils il très dégourdi mais il est
aussi turbulent et même arrogant en
classe il reprend les profs on me
convoquer pour des petits détails vous
comprenez madame c'est gênant pour moi
parce que j'ai d'autres élèves alors
qu'est ce qui se passe oui il me reprend
pour une virgule me reprend un point est
ce que j'ai oublié
voilà alors la fin de ce troisième
erwan décroche son brevet haut la main
il gagne sa liberté il a un bon il fait
des du scooter avec ses copains dans le
quartier et un jour c'est l'accident et
là vous vous dites un jour il va
renverser quelqu'un il n'est pas assuré
ça va être très compliqué et donc vous
décidez lui offrir un scooter alors
quand vous constatez que le scooter
bleus est devenu noir vous comprenez
quand même qu'à roanne commence à filer
du mauvais coton j'avais seulement 10
jatte averti
je ne défendrai pas eu
attention russell attention vol mais non
mais ne t'inquiète pas n'inquiétait pas
effectivement vous avez la certitude
qu'il est en train de changer erwan
quant à la veille de son entrée en
seconde il veut quitter l'école alors
vous lui dites mais tu vas faire quoi
maintenant il vous répond tu verras tu
fais un don qu'il a passé un concours je
ne savais pas passé un bep de froid et
climatisation en une année il a réussi
oui le 29 juin 2007 la police débarque
chez vous erwan est accusé d'avoir
participé au braquage d'un bureau de
tabac et il fêtera ses 18 ans derrière
les barreaux à la prison de luynes alors
il va y passer 18 mois mais finalement
enfin c'est un peu des vacances pour lui
il prend pas ça très mal il ne vit pas
comme une punition très grave et me
disais tiens on nous met des écrans
plats mais même lui surpris mais on a
des playstation est en moi même je me
disais mais qui est en prison
il m'a dit man il m'a dit mais je
retrouve mes collègues
de quartier
et ben non on se pose des questions est
un peu par an en janvier 2009 donc sa
sortie de prison et roanne a eu son dmp
par correspondance et l'avouent
l'éloigner du quartier ça vous allez
vivre dans un appartement des restos du
coeur vous êtes trois dans la même
chambre ce qui est effectivement montre
encore une fois votre votre engagement
pour vos enfants et ils travaillent donc
dans la climatisation et les panneaux
solaires il gagne 1500 euros par mois le
18 juillet 2010 après son sport et une
douche il vous dit qu'il va manger avec
des collègues et il dit ne m'attends pas
maman trois quarts d'heure plus tard ses
collègues débarque chez vous et vous
dise il lui est arrivé quelque chose dès
qu'on sait dans quel hôpital il et on
vous appelle
à l'hôpital vous ne verrez que son
visage parce que son corps est caché
il a pris dix coups de couteau dans le
ventre et dans le coeur
oui je suis rentré
oui j'ai fait mon fils avec un drap
relevé au marteau oui il était déjà
froid oui
le mercredi suivant lors du repas de
deuil un jeune répète en boucle une
phrase en arabe
pardonne moi mon dieu pardonne moi mon
dieu oui il pas un bizarre ces garçons
enfin comme si le repas de deuil nous
avons autre chose à penser vous y faites
pas spécialement attention d'ailleurs ce
garçon va à la morgue pour voir votre
fils et il assistera même enterrement et
trois semaines après l'assassinât
d'erwan
où vous apprend que ce garçon est
l'assassin
oui comme la donner son nom oui j'étais
tellement vide et que je ne ressentais
plus rien plus rien
ma seule réaction était de prendre le
lendemain le téléphone était hier la
police voilà pour les judiciaire voilà
chez ge et le non moins en fait c'est
l'un des quatre braqueurs du bureau de
tabac qui a tué votre fils jean parle à
la police effectivement mais personne ne
veut témoigner dans le quartier alors
qu'il ya des gens qui avaient assisté à
cette histoire c'est la fameuse omerta
et puis en mars dernier on vous prévient
que l'assassin d'erwan est mort on a
retrouvé son corps criblé de balles au
pied d'une tour des quartiers nord
et donc il n'y aura jamais de procès non
je voulais l'affronter je m'attendais à
un procès je m'attendais à à le voir à
m'expliquer je savais qu'il y avait rien
ce qu'il faut ce dire mon fils n'est pas
mort d'un trafic de drogue il n'a jamais
touché à la drogue ça a été un braquage
il a fait de la prison et cet assassinat
a été une bagarre d'une futilité bat na
waie voilà alors malika cette omerta
finalement donc ça veut dire que tout le
monde le savait mais personne à
témoigner pour dire c'est lui donc ça
c'est quand même incroyable ccc salah le
mal et le silence des quartiers sont
peur des représailles ils ont tort je
peux le comprendre mais ce qu'ils ne
savent pas les gens c'est que la justice
comme oui la justice elle protège
donc mais vous vous êtes allé voir des
gens qui savaient vous leur avez dit dit
le par exemple
est-ce qu'ils étaient capables je leur
ai dit est ce que vous êtes capable de
me dire ce que vous m'avez dit de le
dire à la police ils m'ont dit on a
perdu
parce que ce qu'il faut savoir le soir
même de l'assassinât de mon fils on est
venus armés
je tiens le du rhin ses cousins et des
amis
est venu menacer les jeunes dans la cité
alors évidemment si les parents de
l'assassin des rois ne l'avait pas
couverts il serait pas mort donc
aujourd'hui vous vous êtes en droit de
dire aux parents de l'assassin de votre
fils c'est vous qui l'avez tué je me
suis toujours posé la question comment
sa mère pouvait le regarde et comment
elle pouvait lui faire à manger comment
pouvait
partir en vacances pendant que moi je
pleurais monfils comment mois de
décembre elles pouvaient partir seul ou
un chalet à la neige
pendant que moi j'ai pleuré mon fils
pendant que moi j'ai essayé de ramasser
le plus d'éléments possible pour avoir
une justice une arrestation
voilà or le débat de haine mali cam une
grande colère effectivement contre les
familles qui ferme les yeux et
aujourd'hui fait partie d'un collectif
qui s'appelle le collectif du 1er juin
c'est une association de mer qui veulent
briser l'omerta des cités oui je suis
rentré dans ce collectif parce qu'il
fallait que je fasse quelque chose
et on attend prochainement inventé vous
avec madame taubira
monsieur valls ou s'ils voient là parce
qu'on arrange marseille en revanche
marseille en revanche on fait des fêtes
énorme la culture 2013 mais les
quartiers nord on les oublie on finance
le centre vide et puis les quartiers non
il n'existe plus voilà il existe dans
les règlements de comptes mais ensuite
votre témoignage
vous y croyez ça va s'arranger la
réponse elle est dans la durée voilà
donc oui je reste optimiste
je veux qu'on sauve ses futurs jeux wii
donc si si on a le soutien des autorités
si on nous donne les moyens oui pourquoi
pas bien merci c'était le mot de la fin
voilà c'était salut les terriens votre
tour du samedi avec daphné bürki le tube
ça commence le 14 sept ans à 12h45 en
clair il sera là patrick balkany député
maire de levallois
gilles lellouche pour gibraltar en
salles mercredi nicolas bedos la tête
ailleurs chez robert laffont en octobre
d'ici là connu tant elle peut être
routier françois collobert pour
l'association robin des lois et malika
d'ananas merci de votre témoignage
madame
tous ceux qui m'ont aidé à faire cette
émission je vous laisse avec roland et
pour les abonnés à
20h55 jason bourne véritable vous rendez
vous ici parce qu'un trois jeunes
sur canal+ cours faire avec en bonus le
top départ et nicolas gros dégâts dans
tout ça
non
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu